la parole est à monsieur yves censi
monsieur le premier ministre nous
assistons depuis quelques semaines un
authentique déni de démocratie vous avez
provoqué un véritable fiasco politique
sur une réforme qui pourtant au départ
faisait l'objet d'un consensus national
le président de la république françois
hollande ne nous avait promis un
quinquennat il y a quatre ans placée
sous le signe de la normalité
mais monsieur le premier ministre est il
normal de passer en force devant la
représentation nationale et de reculer
devant quelques exaltés qui mobilise
dans la rue les forces de police alors
que nous sommes en état d'urgence
est il normal de piétiner les
partenaires sociaux en considérant comme
monsieur cambadélis qui affirme je le
cite puisque tout le monde est contre
c'est la preuve que ce texte est
équilibré
est il normal encore de museler le
parlement d'abord par le recours à la
procédure d'urgence
et hier par le blocage du vote des
députés dès l'article 1er est il normal
de tordre le bras de la représentation
nationale en brandissant aujourd'hui
l'article 49-3 de notre constitution
procédure qui n'est que le témoin d'une
crise de régime vous êtes contraints de
gouverner contre votre propre majorité
est il normal d'entendre hier matin sur
une grande radio un responsable
socialiste a rappelé aux députés de
votre majorité qui tiraient leur
légitimité non pas du suffrage universel
mais du président de la république et
qu'il ferait bien de s'en rappeler
c'est dire le peu de considération que
vous accordez aux représentants du
peuple français relégué au rang
d'arrière-garde aux ordres d'un monarque
auquel il devrait allégeance et
reconnaissance monsieur le premier
ministre aujourd'hui vous ne gouverner
pas la france vous gouvernez le
psychodrame du parti socialiste alors
aller jusqu'au bout de cette mascarade
et dites-nous quand vous alliez
appliquer le 49-3
merci la parole et à madame myriam elle
comme au ministre du travail de l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député yves censi depuis le
début le gouvernement a montré sa
volonté sincère de dialogue dialogue
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales
nous avons n'ont pas procédé à des
reculs du texte nous avons profité à des
enrichissements du texte pour trouver un
compromis
nous avons par la suite dans le cadre de
la commission affaires sociales et je
tiens ici à saluer l'excellent travail
mené par le rapporteur christophe
sirugue près de mille amendements ont
été examinés au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales
nous en avons retenu un tiers et puis
par la suite
en effet nous avons développé le débat
ici dans l'hémicycle pourquoi parce que
nous souhaitons avancer parce que nous
souhaitons donner toutes les chances à
notre pays parce que nous souhaitons en
effet nous n'avons pas une vision
manille nous n'avions pas une vision
manichéenne de l'entreprise est en effet
nous pensons véritablement que c'est par
le dialogue social que nous pouvons
transformer nos modes de régulation à la
fois pour mieux nous adapter et en même
temps pour renforcer les acteurs parce
que nous considérons également que les
enjeux de au sein de ce projet loi les
protections qu'ils apportent à un moment
il ya des mutations du monde du travail
le fait que nous devons améliorer notre
législation en matière de travail
détachées oui je regrette qu' il n'y ait
pas sur les bancs de la gauche
unanimité sur le sujet mais le plus
essentiel je crois c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
permettra justement demain à nos
entreprises à nous à l'arrêt à nos
jeunes en situation de précarité qui
pourront bénéficier de la garantie
jeunes
qu'est ce que ce texte de loi permettra
également aux contrats saisonniers
également aux roses aux collaborateurs
des plateformes collaboratives voilà
l'intégralité de ce projet là et pour
cela nous devons être fiers de le porter
merci